- LegalEagle is coming
in loud and clear thanks
to Ting Mobile.
Over 70% of Americans say
that they want witnesses
and documents in the
Senate impeachment trial
of Donald Trump that
didn't actually come out
in the House proceedings.
And 70% of Americans
don't agree on anything.
As of the recording of this video,
John Bolton lobbed his own bombshell
that his book allegedly
states that Donald Trump
personally ordered the quid pro quo
of leveraging hundreds
of millions of dollars
of Ukrainian aid for investigations
or announcements of
investigations into the Bidens.
Some want John Bolton
and others to testify.
Some want to prevent John Bolton
and others from testifying.
It's time to think like a lawyer.
(majestic music)
Hey, LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer,
because in this debate a
lot of people are referring
to historical precedent as a reason
to call witnesses or not call witnesses
at the Senate impeachment trial.
But the thing about making appeals
to prior precedent in this context is
that there's not very much of it.
When people say that these
impeachment proceedings
are breaking with precedent
or are unprecedented,
what they mean is that it's not like
the only two other
instances that this happened
in the modern era, because
there's only two instances
that are related to impeachment.
But even the impeachment proceedings
regarding Richard Nixon didn't result
in a formal impeachment in
the House or a Senate trial.
And sometimes it's helpful to refer back
to the impeachment of
Andrew Johnson in the 1830s,
that but is such an odd situation
that it's almost sui
generis and references to it
can be problematic.
I did a prior video on this.
You can check out my
prior impeachment videos
to learn about the
impeachment of Andrew Johnson.
So given that impeachment
is such a rare event
in American politics, precedent
can be of limited value.
It's absolutely instructional,
but it's by no means dispositive.
In this context the argument that I hear
from certain corners of the internet is
that it's the House of Representatives
that does the investigation,
and the Senate
simply looks at the evidence
that the House gathered.
Now, that's not wrong strictly speaking,
but it's also definitely
not entirely true either.
And I also hear people on
both sides of the aisle
make the analogy to criminal law.
The House of Representatives
files an indictment,
i.e. the charging instrument
against a criminal defendant,
and then the Senate tries the case.
And we'll talk about whether
that fits in a second,
but first let's look at what happened
in prior impeachments to understand
why this one is different to the extent
that it is actually different.
Now, I mentioned this in a prior video,
but one of the biggest
differences that stands out to me
as someone that actually
studied the Watergate
and Clinton impeachments
extensively in college
as a former political
scientist and someone
who has studied constitutional law
and separation of powers in law school,
one of the things that really
sticks out to me is that
in both cases there was
an extensive investigation
by the Executive Branch into
the acts of Nixon and Clinton.
And I think it's helpful to go over some
of the timelines for the
Nixon and Clinton impeachments
to understand just how wide ranging
these investigations were.
So let's start with a
really quick timeline of
what happened to Richard Nixon.
As you may know, the
Watergate break-in was
in June of 1972.
- [Reporter] Five people
have been arrested
and charged with breaking
into the headquarters
of the Democratic National Committee
in the middle of the night.
- Then it was almost a
year later that the Senate,
not the House, began
hearings in May of 1973.
- We will inquire into every fact
and follow every lead,
unrestrained by any fear
of where that lead might
ultimately take us.
- That was a year later.
Oh, and by the way,
speaking of those Senate
Watergate hearings, during
those hearings several
of Nixon's cabinet
members, aids, and advisors
actually gave testimony,
including his Attorney General,
his Chief of Staff, his
top domestic advisor,
and White House counsel.
They all gave testimony before the Senate.
After the Senate hearings
into the Watergate break-in,
Attorney General Elliott
Richardson appointed
Archibald Cox special
prosecutor in May of 1973.
So effectively Richard
Nixon's own attorney general
appointed a special prosecutor right
after the Senate started hearing.
And two months after
Archibald Cox was appointed
special prosecutor he subpoenaed
the famous Nixon tapes
from the White House.
- We will initiate such legal measures
to secure the eight tapes
and certain other evidence
as soon as proper papers can be prepared.
- Of course, famously,
the White House refused
to comply with the special
prosecutor's subpoena
and didn't turn the tapes over.
At that point the special
prosecutor went to court
and the case went to the Court of Appeals,
which didn't actually rule
until October of 1973.
And in a five to two
decision, the Court of Appeals
ordered the White House
to turn over the tapes.
But at that point the White House resisted
and refused to turn the tapes over
to the special prosecutor.
This is in Fall of 1973.
The Nixon White House
did offer a compromise,
which I think is one of
the funnier footnotes
of the whole Watergate affair.
Nixon offered to turn the tapes over,
which were famously low
quality, to Senator Stennis,
who was famously almost deaf.
And the compromise was
that Senator Stennis
would review these
tapes and then turn over
any inculpatory evidence
to the special prosecutor,
the idea being that there was
no way he could actually hear
what was being discussed on
the tapes, but I digress.
What's important here is that
despite the Court of Appeals
ordering the White House to comply,
Nixon refused to comply with
the Court of Appeals decision,
and in fact ordered AG Richardson
to fire Archibald Cox.
- The president at that point
thought he had no choice
but to direct the attorney
general to discharge Mr. Cox.
I felt equally clear that
I could not discharge him,
and so I resigned.
- Attorney General Richardson refused
to actually fire Archibald
Cox, but as a result
the president fired AG Richardson,
which resulted in the famous
Saturday Night Massacre,
which resulted in not only
AG Richardson resigning
but also Archibald Cox being fired as well
by Robert Bork.
Shortly thereafter
Archibald Cox was replaced
by Special Prosecutor Leon Jaworski,
who continued the investigation.
- I was given unqualified assurance
that there would be
absolutely no constraints
on my freedom to seek
any and all evidence.
- Now, a formal impeachment
inquiry did not start
until February, 1974, and
it wasn't until July of 1974
that the Supreme Court
issued the unanimous decision
in United States versus Nixon to turn over
the Nixon White House tapes.
And finally, it wasn't until August, 1974
that the tapes were actually released.
These are the famous
smoking gun Nixon tapes.
In fact, Nixon resigned in August of 1974
shortly after these tapes were released,
in part because the
Executive wasn't willing
to contradict the Supreme
Court at that point.
- I shall resign the presidency
effective at noon tomorrow.
- And he resigned before he
was even formally impeached
by the House or tried by the Senate.
So in terms of takeaways
that we all should be able
to agree upon from the Nixon
Watergate impeachment affair,
I think there are a couple
things that we can glean.
Number one, there was a massive
Executive Branch investigation
before the House was even involved.
And the House and the special prosecutor
didn't even get involved
before there were hearings
at the Senate.
This investigation by the
special prosecutor's office
of the Executive Branch
took literally years.
It was also obstructed by the White House
and required not just a
Court of Appeals decision
but also a decision by the
United States Supreme Court.
And on top of that, the investigation
by the special prosecutor was started
by Attorney General Elliott Richardson,
who is the equivalent of Bill Barr today.
Part of the difference
that we see today is
that Attorney General Bill Barr refused
to start any investigation
into the Ukrainian allegations.
That's the reason it's
alleged that the whistleblower
came forward and had to blow a whistle,
there was no action by
the Executive Branch.
That's why the whistleblower
is a whistleblower.
The Executive Branch, including
Attorney General Bill Barr,
counsel for the CIA and
White House counsel,
did nothing about the
Zelensky conversation
or the other actions that are alleged.
Another takeaway is that this litigation
involving the subpoena of the
White House tapes took years.
It was incredibly time consuming,
as litigation tends to be.
As you may know, in the federal courts,
what you're talking
about is a trial court,
which is a district court,
and then the trial court's
decision is appealed
to the court of appeals, and only then,
after the court of appeals
has weighed in on the subject
can something go to the Supreme Court.
And here we've seen examples
where that litigation
has taken an extremely long time.
Right now there are ongoing cases
regarding the litigation of
Donald Trump's tax returns
and the litigation of the allegation
that the Trump Hotel is
an improper emolument
and is a benefit to the president.
In fact, with respect to
the emoluments litigation,
one of those cases has already
gone to the court of appeal
and was remanded back down
to the district courts.
So it's sort of back where it started.
So it's a long way from
getting to the Supreme Court.
And believe it or not, the
litigation in the Nixon case
where the Supreme Court
didn't actually issue
a formal decision until late
1974, that's actually fast.
It usually takes a lot longer than that
for a case to be adjudicated
by the Supreme Court.
So that's the impeachment of
Richard Nixon in a nutshell,
but let's talk about the
impeachment of Bill Clinton.
That impeachment starts in 1994,
even though it didn't resolve until 1999.
In the Clinton proceedings,
Kenneth Starr was appointed
as independent counsel in August of 1994,
with the approval of
Attorney General Janet Reno.
In the wake of the Nixon impeachment,
the special prosecutor
statutes were replaced
with the independent
counsel statutes later on.
So Kenneth Starr was appointed in 1994
to investigate what's called
the White Water affair,
which are certain real estate
related allegations related to
when Clinton was in private practice.
And although Kenneth Starr was appointed
to investigate the White Water affair,
the investigation broadened over time
to include a number of different things,
including the death of Vince Foster,
the firing of certain White
House travel office personnel,
potential abuse of confidential FBI files,
and eventually the Paula Jones lawsuit
and eventually the possible perjury
and obstruction of justice to cover up
President Clinton's sexual relationship
with Monica Lewinsky.
And to this day part of the controversy
over the Starr investigation
is that it started
regarding the White
Water issue but ballooned
into including something else entirely
over the course of five to six years
and took on subsequent
controversies as they came up.
Roughly at the same time in 1994
Paul Jones filed suit and
accused President Clinton
of sexual harassment when
he was governor of Arkansas.
Clinton attempted to delay
the trial, the civil trial,
over the Paul Jones lawsuit
until after he left office.
But in May of 1997 the
Supreme Court unanimously
rejected Clinton's claim
that the constitution
immunized him from civil lawsuits.
And shortly thereafter
pre-trial discovery commenced
in the Paula Jones lawsuit.
As part of the Paul Jones lawsuit,
in January of 1998
Clinton gave a deposition
in the Jones litigation where he denied
having a sexual relationship
with Monica Lewinsky.
- I, I have never had sexual relations
with Monica Lewinsky, I've
never had an affair with her.
- A few months later in August of 1998
President Clinton testified in front
of a grand jury convened by the Office
of Independent Counsel,
i.e. Kenneth Starr,
and actually testified for four hours
about his relationship
with Monica Lewinsky
and whether he had
perjured himself before.
- I knew that in the face
of their illegal activity
I still had to behave lawfully.
But I wanted to be legal without
being particularly helpful.
- You might have heard
of the famous testimony
of President Clinton where he says,
"It depends on what your
definition of is is."
Well, this is where it comes from,
from the testimony in front
of the grand jury in 1998.
- It depends upon what the
meaning of the word is is.
- A few months later in September of 1998,
Kenneth Starr and the Office
of Independent Counsel
concluded its four year long
investigation of the president
soon after the president's
grand jury testimony
and delivered the famous Starr Report
to the House Judiciary Committee.
The Starr Report itself was extensive.
It was 453 pages long.
Republican House leaders argued
for the report's immediate
release via the internet,
which was new at the time,
while the Democrats tried
to delay to allow the White
House time to form a response.
But after two days of debate,
on September 11, 1998,
the House voted in a huge majority
to release the report to the public,
after which formal impeachment
of President Clinton
started in October of 1998,
really just a month after
the Starr Report came out.
Just a few months later
in December of 1998
the House voted to
impeach President Clinton.
And in January of 1999
the Senate began its trial
of President Clinton.
In February of 1999
the Senate began taking
closed door depositions of witnesses,
and in that same month
the Senate voted 70 to 30
that excerpting the videotapes
of these closed door
depositions would suffice
as testimony rather than
calling live witnesses
to appear at trial.
And then famously Bill Clinton
was acquitted in the Senate.
- Two-thirds of the Senators present
not having pronounced him guilty,
the Senate adjudges that the respondent,
William Jefferson Clinton,
President of the United States,
is not guilty as charged.
- So what are the takeaways
from the Clinton impeachment proceedings?
Well, once again we have
a massive investigation
by the Executive Branch, this time
from the Office of Independent Counsel.
That investigation took multiple years,
basically five years from start to finish.
And the House didn't really
do the investigation at all.
In fact, it was just a matter of days
between the release of the Starr Report
and impeachment proceedings and eventually
actual formal impeachment by the House.
On top of that, the president
testified multiple times,
both in depositions in civil court
in the Paula Jones
litigation, a deposition
in the Senate trial, and
in front of the grand jury
pursuant to the
investigation of the Office
of Independent Counsel.
And as with the impeachment
of Richard Nixon,
it required a decision by
the U.S. Supreme Court.
Even though Paula Jones
started her litigation in 1994,
it wasn't until 1997 that
the Supreme Court said
that the president was not immune
and that the civil suit could go forward
and the president could be deposed.
And if we're specifically
talking about witnesses
in the trial before the Senate,
well, there's not a lot of history here
when it comes to impeachment
trials and presidents.
It's only happened twice,
with Andrew Johnson in 1868
and Bill Clinton in 1999.
In the impeachment case
of Andrew Johnson in 1868,
there were actually 41 witnesses called.
And in the case of Bill
Clinton, there were three,
including Monica Lewinsky herself.
So with that historical
context, let's talk
about the analogy that the House indicts,
because impeachment is like an indictment,
and the idea that the Senate tries it
because they have the power
to try the impeachment.
So in the American criminal law context,
you can start a criminal
prosecution with some
but not all of the evidence that you want.
Indictment is a very low standard.
And you can get more
evidence at and during trial.
In a civil case you get
what's called discovery,
which is meant to prevent you
from being ambushed at trial,
but even there you can
get new evidence at trial
if it wasn't available earlier on.
And in the criminal law
context, you often hear
from witnesses for the
very first time at trial
because you don't get discovery
in a criminal case often.
And it can also be true that
the evidence is overwhelming
at the indictment stage,
but it could also be true
that you want more evidence
at the time of trial.
It can also be true that
you have some evidence
at the start, or at the indictment phase,
but that you need more
evidence to meet the hurdle
that is required for conviction.
The standard for indictment
is incredibly low,
it's probable cause, probable
cause that some conduct
that gives rise to the crime
or the offense is elicited.
But the standard for conviction
is beyond a reasonable doubt
which is much, much higher.
And criminal investigations
are always ongoing,
so you might have to file
an indictment to, say,
beat a statute of limitations problem,
and then you go forward with
trial as new things come about.
In fact, in many states
prosecutors can actually
withhold evidence from
defendants until trial,
so every defendant gets new information
and new evidence when the trial starts.
But again, these are just analogies,
these aren't required by the Constitution.
The Constitution requires
neither probable cause
nor guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
at the impeachment or conviction stage.
The House and Senate can use
whatever standards they want,
which is why impeachment is
often called a political tool.
Sometimes the analogies break down.
The House isn't a police
force or an office
of district attorneys,
they have some tools,
but generally speaking criminal defendants
don't get to claim executive privilege
or block witnesses from testifying
at the criminal investigation
or trial of that defendant.
And generally criminal
defendants don't get
to control the investigation of the police
or decide if there even
is an investigation
in the first place.
So are these impeachment
proceedings different
from the other two modern
impeachment proceedings?
Well, yes, they couldn't not be,
but that begs the question
that it's different
in an improper way.
Here, a lot stems from Attorney
General Barr's inaction.
You could say that the House didn't do
the same kind of thorough investigation
that the House did in the
Nixon and Clinton affairs
or that they rushed the investigation,
but the House has never had to carry
the investigatory laboring oar before.
In the last two modern impeachments,
there was always a massive
Executive Branch investigation.
And although we don't know everything
about John Bolton's
testimony, in part because
he hasn't given it yet, it's possible
that Attorney General
Barr is conflicted out.
By all accounts he may
have buried concerns
about the Zelensky call,
Rudy Giuliani's actions,
and the whistleblower.
Again, we don't know the details here,
but that's also kind of the point.
One wonders what history would look like
if Attorney General
Richardson had stonewalled
and never appointed Archibald Cox.
Or if Janet Reno had quashed
Ken Starr's appointment
as the independent counsel
and never investigated
the White Water investigation.
Any of the Trump related legal questions
would not have been resolved
by the U.S. Supreme Court
until almost certainly
after the 2020 election.
This gives talking points to both sides.
Some will claim that
it was the House's duty
to engage in that litigation,
and some will say that it was futile.
There's certainly no
constitutional requirement
for the House to go forward, but again,
that tactic gives talking
points to both sides.
All things being equal,
I would certainly love
for the Supreme Court to
weigh in on these questions,
in part because I think it's clear
how the Supreme Court would weigh in
given the precedent of
U.S. versus Nixon in 1973,
Clinton verus Jones, and
U.S. versus Nixon in 1993,
which is a different Nixon.
But I suppose that what you think the role
of the House, the Senate
and the Supreme Court is
in this context is a political question
and reasonable minds
can differ about that.
But at base there's nothing
constitutionally infirm
about the length of time or
the amount of investigation
that the House did, it's not required
by the Constitution to call every witness
that might have relevant testimony.
And here history and
precedent certainly diverge.
It's not wrong to say that in the past
the House has investigated the evidence
about impeachable conduct.
But it's also not entirely right either.
In the past the House has had the benefit
of a huge Executive Branch investigation.
Ironically, for Nixon and Clinton,
it would probably be most accurate to say
that it wasn't the House that investigated
so much as the Executive
Branch that investigated itself
with assists from the
United States Supreme Court,
which the House then relied on.
It is, however, wrong to say
that witnesses are improper
at the Senate trial.
It happened with the
Senate impeachment trial
of President Clinton and happened
with the Senate impeachment
trial of President Johnson,
though for reasons I've
talked about in other videos
the impeachment of Andrew Johnson
is kind of a weird animal.
So to argue that these proceedings comport
with past precedent or diverge
from past precedent is more
like the start of the
conversation rather than the end.
We've only had two Senate trials in all
of American history, and
in those particular cases
there were witnesses.
And, of course, it's also
factually incorrect to say
that the House had no
evidence and no witnesses
when it voted to impeach President Trump.
They had lots of evidence,
but whether you think
that was enough to vote for impeachment
and even the standard that
the House of Representatives
should use to decide if
there is enough evidence is
probably another political
question that I leave to you.
But whether the House rushed
the impeachment hearing
and the impeachment decision
is probably inchoate
to the question of whether there should be
additional evidence and
witnesses at the Senate trial.
Again, going back to the analogy
of a criminal indictment,
so long as the House had enough to suspect
presidential wrongdoing, then it's enough
to send it to the Senate.
And if the Senate wants
more evidence and witnesses,
or if it needs more
evidence and witnesses,
it doesn't mean that the
House investigation was infirm
or that the evidence was weak.
It just might mean that
there's other relevant evidence
out there and that the
Senate wants to see it.
But the bottom line is that the Senate
will soon vote on additional
witnesses, documents,
and subpoenas in the Senate trial.
And it's more important than
ever to call your Senator
and tell them that you are part of the 75%
of Americans who want witnesses,
and maybe even the testimony
of President Trump,
as in the Clinton proceedings.
The phone numbers of the
most important senators are
in the description, and if
you're going to make that call
and yell at your senator,
you might as well save a ton
of money with Ting Mobile.
Ting Mobile is a different
kind of mobile provider.
With Ting you only pay for the actual data
and services you use at
the end of the month.
And because you're only paying
for what you actually use,
Ting customers pay on
average just $23 per month
for one of their mobile devices.
There is no contract, overage fees
or any other carrier tricks.
You just pay a fair
price for the talk, text,
and data that you use up every month.
And Ting has award-winning
customer service.
Because they don't have any
brick and mortar stores,
they pour their resources
into their phone support.
If you have an issue, give them a call,
and you'll immediately
talk to a real human being.
And if you're like me and you
would rather avoid talking
to any actual real human
beings, they offer support
through chat, email, social
media, and even Discord.
With Ting you can use
almost any cell phone,
including the newest
iPhones and pixel phones.
And you can use the same phone number
that you're using right now.
Ting provides excellent LTE coverage
because it uses both the
T-Mobile and Sprint networks.
So even if the FTC blocks
the merger of Sprint
and T-Mobile, you can still
get the best of both worlds.
And with Ting, especially
if you're around wifi
all the time, which most of us are,
you'll end up paying way
less than you do now.
Sure, it might make sense for some people
to pay $200 per month for unlimited data,
but if you're surrounded
by wifi all day long,
you might be paying hundreds
of dollars more per month
completely unnecessarily.
Ting gives you the option to
pay for only what you use.
So if you go to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would
save if you switch to Ting,
if you'd save anything at all.
And LegalEagles will get a $25 credit
just by going to LegalEagle.Ting.com
or clicking the link in the description.
And that could cover literally
the entire first month
of your cell phone bill with Ting.
And since there are no contracts,
you can try it for a
month, no strings attached.
Again, all you have to
do is click on the link
in the description or go
to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
get a $25 credit for
whatever service you want.
Plus, clicking on the link
really helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that there
should be witnesses
in the Senate trial, or do
you think that the House
really screwed the pooch
in their investigation?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this
playlist of all my other
real law reactions where I talk about
impeachment-related things, copyright,
all of the legal news that's in the news
and is fit to print.
Just click on the playlist.